Kia Ora, we’re here at Woodend Beach at one of
our emergency warning sirens.
These sounded the night of the November Kaikoura
earthquake.  There was some confusion around
what the sirens meant, and who had to evacuate.
Civil Defence is running a series of public
information nights in the coastal communities
of the Waimakairi District.
This is your opportunity to hear the latest
advice from our experts, to learn more about
how the warning siren system operates and
ask us any questions you may have.
Be prepared for Tsunami emergencies.
Tell you neighbours, come along and know what
to do for next time.
All meetings start at 7pm.
16 March – Woodend Community Centre
22 March – Pegasus Bay School Hall
27 March – Kaiapoi Rugby Clubrooms
6 April – Pines / Kairaki Yacht Club